we're not even married to bacon it is
the name it could be spectacular or
bake's caliber or what's not bad master
bakers absolutely no okay
welcome to baking it one team will win
the 50 000
prize
i was gonna say the journey not the
money
that's what my lower back tattoo says
i'm not gonna go so far as to say we
were born for this i mean some of us
were i would say having kids was the
best thing ever happened to me until
this show
now this is like my real baby you know
what i mean
yes
what are you making pudding three ways i
did a lot of those in college putting
three ways now our judges are here to do
what grandmothers do best judge you
because they love you and think you can
do better it's great delicious so good i
don't agree with you on that one what
you do i think it's undercooked the
grandchildren tell me all the times oh
grandma you shouldn't say that and i
just say
i want a cake that makes me go
what
and then
time to get dirty
i love the holidays and that's what
baking is all about it brings people
together
i could not be left alone with this cake
because i know what i do with king cakes
at home we don't well what were you
thinking
i what
[Music]
you